The Joe Rogan Experience that's the
heartbeat of Vegas the industry the
Vegas industry I'll live off the strip
right the dancers The Magicians the uh
the bottle service girls all those girls
and all the people Summerlin Henderson
so I was there for two two and a half
years it was great it was during the
pandemic I lived next to Nicholas Cage
yeah which was cool carrot Top's
actually the one that um reintroduced me
to him
so um and I had known Nicholas Cage
because we went to the same High School
from back in the day so uh uh so when we
connected it was [__] it was weird
because I'm like you huge fan yeah I
mean I mean he's been doing it for 40
years and his movies are you know he's
one of the best actors so when I'm he'll
he'll hit me up he'll be like yo come
out let's go and then he'll like text me
and he'll be in his 500 000
um you know Ferrari I'm like where are
we going so we're gonna get some sushi
so we'll go get sushi and then we'll
drive down Las Vegas Boulevard I'm like
dude you don't need he's got eight cars
I'm like you don't need this he goes
yeah but it's badass that's his answer
to it it's badass I'm like all right
he's correct it's true and this house is
awesome yeah but you're like you're a
little more sensible okay yeah what are
you doing Nick yeah slow down he's
trying to be in a cage yeah he is he's
doing it he loves it
and his house is cool and he's he's he's
great very very but he doesn't you know
he's not on social media we signed an
NDA
he made me sign an NDA wow that I can't
like put any videos or photos anywhere
no I'm just kidding he didn't sign it
but I'm just saying but but he but the
one of the first conversations with him
is when I came over to his house he's
like he's like come over you're my
neighbor out of nowhere right
so I come over we start having a nice
glass of wine and he says I'm not doing
your podcast I'm like I didn't ask you
to [__] be on the podcast I'm just
here what's up and he goes just one
thing promise me he goes don't ever you
know post any pictures or videos of us
together because I want to be private
I'm like cool and ever since then it's
been it's been cool yeah that's cool but
I do have a lot of photos and videos of
his penis
but he is funny dude I'm sure he is yeah
he seems like a real character and it's
so funny that he changed his last name
because he was connected to Francis Ford
Coppola right because because of his his
nephew is that what it is yeah no what
he said what what Nick said is when he
first started acting he was on the set
of I think it was Fast Times at
Ridgemont High he was with uh I think it
was Sean Penn and you know there was
different different actors and they go
oh you're just here because your uncle
is Francis Ford Coppola so he didn't
want to be known as that so so so he
didn't want to be known as that so he
wanted his own identity and it worked
you know because
um America or the world they don't think
like oh that's Francis Ford Coppola's
nephew you know because his because his
father was Francis Ford Coppola's
brother right that was in the 60 Minutes
thing right yeah we talked about in
there the 60 Minutes things were fun it
was very fun but that's what a great
move too and name yourself after a
[__] superhero Nick Cage
it's awesome yeah and he's been at so
many fun movies man yeah
I mean that guy was in um
what's the Arizona movie grazing Arizona
Raising Arizona yeah I mean Moonstruck
yeah leaving Las Vegas I mean they're
just [__] amazing
so many so many [__] great movies
yeah yeah he's a good dude we hang out
at this uh sushi bar in Vegas on Sahara
it's pretty good
um and we just you know he's just you
know he's very sensitive as you can
imagine but he's a sweetheart I'm sure I
would expect nothing wrong yeah
smart of him of staying off social media
too yeah
yeah it's not his thing you don't need
it anyway
your Nicholas Cage and he goes from uh
he goes from one movie to the next movie
to the next movie and he loves acting
dude how about leaving Las Vegas yeah
remember that movie hell yeah holy [__]
yeah that movie was heavy
yeah heavy
did you see Pig no that's his favorite
movie that he did really you gotta watch
Pig it's really good yeah yeah it's
[__] great
that and guest house my movie guest
house
watch watch mine stoned
um yeah look at him right there
what is pig about
someone steals as someone steals his
Truffle Pig oh no yeah and he's not
happy about it oh he looks wild as [__]
yeah look at him where's he supposed to
be living
um I think it's in Portland in the woods
oh wow yeah
he's such a sweetheart he's such a great
guy and such a you know I'm very um you
know happy that I got to connect with
him who has my pick is this an action
movie does he [__] people up it's like a
drama movie is there like John Wick with
pigs no not quite not quite but close I
guess this is all those movies like you
[__] with the wrong guy yeah there's so
many movies like that